le dernier jour touche à sa fin 24
Forum économique de Saint-Pétersbourg
qui est unique
les événements mondiaux sont en fait les seuls
pandémie d'abord
événements qui ont eu lieu dans le monde
formule temps plein
qui a recueilli une somme sans précédent
nombre de conditions de la situation des participants
événement principal de niveau unique
c'était la séance plénière d'hier
il y avait beaucoup de choses intéressantes dessus
discuté de questions, y compris
la principale question c'est moi aussi, puisque
Tout le monde a regardé tout ce dépassement
conséquences de la pandémie
et débriefing
l'impact de la pandémie sur les économies des pays
seulement dans la discussion de la question a été
a attiré plus de 1300 conférenciers et
experts